high level what is GPT for how does it
work and uh what to use most amazing
about it
it's a system that we'll look back at
and say it was a very early Ai and it
will it's slow it's buggy it doesn't do
a lot of things very well but neither
did the very earliest computers
and they still pointed a path to
something that was going to be really
important in our lives even though it
took a few decades to evolve do you
think this is a pivotal moment like out
of all the versions of GPT 50 years from
now
when they look back at an early system
yeah that was really kind of a leap you
know in a Wikipedia page about the
history of artificial intelligence which
which of the gpts what they put that is
a good question I sort of think of
progress as this continual exponential
in it's not like we could say here was
the moment where AI went from not
happening happening and I'd have a very
hard time like pinpointing a single
thing I think it's this very continual
curve
well the history books write about GPT
one or two or three or four or seven
that's for them to decide I don't I
don't really know I think
if I had to pick some moment from what
we've seen so far I'd sort of picked
chat GPT
you know it wasn't the underlying model
that mattered it was the usability of it
both the rlhf and the interface to it
what is Jazzy BTU what is rlhf
reinforcement learning with human
feedback what was that little magic
ingredient
to the dish that made it uh so much more
delicious
so we we trained these models uh on a
lot of Text data and in that process
they they learned the underline
something about the underlying
representations of what's in here or in
there and they can do
amazing things but when you first play
with that base model that we call it
after you finish training
can do very well on evals it can pass
tests it can do a lot of you know
there's knowledge in there but it's not
very useful
uh or at least it's not easy to use
let's say and rlhf is how we take some
human feedback the simplest version of
this is show two outputs ask which one
is better than the other uh which one
the human Raiders prefer and then feed
that back into the model with
reinforcement learning and that process
works remarkably well within my opinion
remarkably little data to make the model
you're more useful so rohf is how we
align the model to what humans want it
to do so there's a giant language model
that's trained in a giant data set to
create this kind of background wisdom
knowledge that's contained within the
internet
and then
somehow adding a little bit of human
guidance on top of it through this
process
makes it seem so much more awesome
maybe just because it's much easier to
use it's much easier to get what you
want you get it right more often the
first time and ease of use matters a lot
even if the base capability was there
before and like a feeling like it
understood the question you're asking or
like it feels like you're kind of on the
same page it's trying to help you is the
feeling of alignment yes I mean that
could be a more technical term for
and you're saying that not much data is
required for that not much human
supervision is required for that to be
fair we understand the science of this
part at a much
earlier stage than we do the science of
creating these large pre-trained models
in the first place but yes less data
much less data that's so interesting the
science of human guidance
that's a very interesting science and
it's going to be a very important
science to understand
how to make it usable how to make it
wise how to make it ethical how to make
it align in terms of all the kind of
stuff we think about
uh and it matters which are the humans
what is the process of incorporating
that human feedback and what are you
asking the humans is it two things that
you're asking them to rank things what
aspects are you letting or asking the
humans to focus in on is it's really
fascinating but um
how uh what is the data set it's trained
on can you kind of loosely speak to the
enormity of this data so pre-training
data set the pre-training data setup
apologize we spend a huge amount of
effort pulling that together from many
different sources
um there's like a lot of there are open
source databases of of information uh we
get stuff via Partnerships there's
things on the Internet it's a lot of our
work is building a great data set
how much of it is the memes subreddit
not very much maybe it'd be more fun if
it were more uh so some of it is Reddit
some of his knee sources all like a huge
number of newspapers there's like the
general web there's a lot of content in
the world more than I think most people
think yeah there is uh like too much
like where like the task is not to find
stuff but to filter out yeah right yeah
was is there a magic to that because
that there seems to be several
components to solve
the uh the design of the you could say
algorithms like their architecture the
neural networks maybe the size of the
neural network there's the selection of
the data
there's the the uh human supervised
aspect of it with you know RL with human
feedback yeah I think one thing that is
not that well understood about creation
of this final product like what it takes
to make gbt4 the version of it we
actually ship out and that you get to
use inside of child GPT the number of
pieces
that have to all come together and then
we have to figure out either new ideas
or just execute existing ideas really
well at every stage of this pipeline
um there's quite a lot that goes into it
so there's a lot of problem solving like
you've already said uh for gpt4 in in
the blog post and in general
there's already kind of a maturity
that's happening on some of these steps
like being able to predict before doing
the full training of well how the model
will behave isn't that so remarkable by
the way that there's like you know
there's like a lot of science that lets
you predict for these inputs here's
what's going to come out the other end
like here's the level of intelligence
you can expect is it close to a science
or is it still
uh because you said the word law in
science which are very ambitious terms
close to us close to right all right
let's be accurate yes I'll say it's way
more scientific than I ever would have
dared to imagine so you can really know
the uh The Peculiar characteristics of
the fully trans system from just a
little bit of training you know like any
new branch of science there's we're
gonna discover new things that don't fit
the data and have to come up with better
explanations and you know that is the
ongoing process of Discovery in science
but with what we know now even what we
had in that gpd4 blog post like I think
we should all just like be in awe of how
amazing it is that we can even predict
to this current level yeah you look at a
one-year-old baby and predict
how it's going to do on the SATs I don't
know uh seemingly an equivalent one but
because here we can actually in detail
introspect various aspects of the system
you can predict
that said uh just to jump around you
said
the language model that is gpt4
it learns in quotes something
uh in terms of science and art and so on
is there within open AI within like
folks like yourself and Alias discover
and the engineers a deeper and deeper
understanding of what that something is
or is it still a kind of um
beautiful Magical Mystery
well there's all these different evals
that we could talk about
and what's an eval oh like how we how we
measure a model as we're training it
after we've trained it and say like you
know how good is this it's some set of
tasks and also just a small tangent
thank you for sort of opening sourcing
the evaluation process yeah I think
that'll be really helpful
um
but the one that really matters is
and we pour all of this effort and money
and time into this thing and then what
it comes out with like how useful is
that to people how much delight does
that bring people how much does that
help them create a much better World new
science new products new Services
whatever
and that's the one that matters
and understanding for a particular set
of inputs like how much value and
utility to provide to people I think we
are understanding that better
um
do we understand everything about why
the model does one thing and not one
other thing certainly not not always but
I would say we are pushing back like
the fog of War more and more and and we
are
you know it took a lot of understanding
to make gpt4 for example but I'm not
even sure we can ever fully understand
like you said you would understand by
asking it questions essentially because
it's compressing all of the web like a
huge sloth of the web into a small
number of parameters
into one organized black box that is
human wisdom
what is that human knowledge let's say
human knowledge
it's a good difference
is there a difference between knowledge
there's others facts and there's wisdom
and I feel like gpt4 can be also full of
wisdom what's the leap from Fast to
wisdom you know a funny thing about the
way we're training these models is
I suspect too much of the like
processing power for lack of a better
word is going into
using the model as a database instead of
using the model as a reasoning engine
yeah the thing that's really amazing
about this system is that it for some
definition of reasoning and we could of
course quibble about it and there's
plenty for which definitions this
wouldn't be accurate but for some
definition
it can do some kind of reasoning and you
know maybe like the scholars and and the
experts and like the armchair
quarterbacks on Twitter would say no it
can't you're misusing the word you're
you know whatever whatever but I think
most people have who have used this
system would say okay it's doing
something in this direction
and
and I think that's
remarkable and the thing that's most
exciting
and somehow out of
ingesting human knowledge it's coming up
with this
reasoning capability however we want to
talk about that
um now in some senses I think that will
be additive to human wisdom and in some
other senses you can use gpt4 for all
kinds of things and say that appears
that there's no wisdom in here
whatsoever
yeah at least in interactions with
humans it seems to possess wisdom
especially when there's a continuous
interaction of multiple problems so I
think what uh on the chat GPT side it
says
the dialog format
makes it possible for Chad gbt to answer
follow-up questions admit its mistakes
challenge incorrect premises and reject
an appropriate requests but also there's
a feeling like it's struggling with
ideas
yeah it's always tempting to
anthropomorphize this stuff too much but
I also feel that way